during the presidential debates donald
trump declared he did not make any money
from china
but we at forbes estimate that since
taking office trump has received at
least
5.4 million dollars from a chinese
state-owned bank
this is because of a lease agreement the
chinese bank has in trump tower
so the industrial and commercial bank of
china signed a lease with donald trump
and trump tower years before he became a
presidential candidate
for 20 000 square feet in the building
and they were going to pay about 1.9
million dollars a year
once donald trump decides that he's
going to run for president he doesn't
get rid of that deal and then once he
becomes president
he doesn't get rid of that deal because
he holds on to all of his business
empire
so all of a sudden you have a
state-owned bank in china paying the
president of the united states millions
of dollars
while he's serving in office trump was
well aware of the deal
he even showed three forbes journalists
visiting the tower in 2015 that the bank
was renting from him
when trump moved into the white house in
2017 he still retained ownership of
retail and
office space in the tower and the
industrial and commercial bank of china
was still a tenant so the chinese bank
was paying donald trump who still owns
100 percent
of the entity that was accepting money
about 1.9 million dollars per year
and the lease was set to expire in
october of 2019 so if you just do the
math
on that amount of rent for trump's first
year in 2017 for second year in 2018
then for most of the third year in 2019
you get to about 5.4 million dollars
coming in from that one lease then we
get some mystery about how much they're
currently paying
we know that the chinese bank has stayed
in trump tower
but the trump organization won't say
exactly how much space
it remained in nor will it say how much
money the bank is paying so
right now it appears that the government
of china is paying the president of the
united states
and no one knows how much money is
involved the arrangement did pose legal
concerns
since the u.s constitution prohibits
federal officials from accepting any
present
emolument office or title or any kind
whatever from any king
prince or foreign state without
congressional approval
on january 11th of 2017 trump and his
team held a press conference at the
tower
and one of his lawyers claimed routine
business transactions were not a
violation of the constitution
she added trump planned on donating all
foreign government profits to the us
treasury
but this doesn't seem to be the case the
trump organization reportedly donated a
total of 343 thousand dollars to the
treasury in 2017
and 2018 but for those same two years
a document connected to trump towers
suggests the chinese bank was set to pay
about 3.9 million dollars in rent
the fundamental question here is is the
president of the united states violating
the constitution
and donald trump not only has this lease
in trump tower
but he's also least space to the bank of
india and 555 california street
the qatar investment authority leave
space in 555 california street as well
the abu dhabi tourism and culture
authority had space inside trump tower
at the beginning of trump's tenure in
office it does not anymore but right
there that's four
foreign governments that were releasing
space in his buildings
and then you go to for example the trump
international hotel in washington dc
where foreign governments are constantly
staying and paying for
hotel rooms and for food and all of that
all of it adds up to something that's
totally unprecedented because no
previous president has kept such a large
business that offers all these entry
points
for foreign governments to be able to
pay him while he serves in office
[Music]
you